yeah so I'll explain what you just
dumped your shoes here
well I stepped in a clump of red and
make up application so there it is I got
to get this out later but I was leaving
little dots of me in the carpeting as I
was walking around but I was bleeding
but turns out let's make up so we're
good oh look show car tracks that's
right
you went this way I'm gonna get that
Westerly Joker there you are boom
just put your beaker on your head that's
the way we do this isn't there any other
landmark that points us in the right
direction
oh there it is a big explosion it was
huge
Wow I think that's where Wendy's was hmm
no things for Wendy was that was her
middle name when B so first name is when
no no not what deep went it with a why
not like Billy Dee he was in the other
building where is my hat without my
glasses I can't see black I'm black
where'd you go to come where'd you go
I'm right here my Tacoma right here oh
my god a floating head Rebecca oh wait
oh hey thanks floating pair of hands oh
hi you ready do the scene yeah okay he's
mine you explain this what location is
this supposed to be an olive beach
underground Arby's yes the basement of
all B's you tell me that Arby's is not
planning some sir hostile takeover that
explained how wide the food is so bad
boo they're making poison and they're
testing it out in the food before they
release their poison bomb and you will
you eat it August then let us see what
evil using my SuperDuper detective
skills
I found your headquarters doing what no
other cop could I can't wanna just crap
oh you want to see a magic trick
how about I make this pencil disappear
up your anus that's a pen it's a
mechanical pencil come on work with me
here Oh supposed to be
you take a bad credit card okay whenever
Batman it's a Black Betty yes yes
Catwoman a piece of here
hey this is making it more hard for me
to talk is in order you don't beats us
to mass my nice they're never going to
deliver to us again again
Malcolm Joker strikes again do you have
any idea how much it's gonna cost to
clean this they may cause an entire
bottle of Windex over the place today
yes you're here you're there you're
everywhere help you can afford cycle
yeah can I get a shroom and Swiss
sandwich can I also get some curly fries
fine guy get a large milkshake the guys
dating no I think I'm good
can I still order breakfast you know
what just the sandwich to them yeah hey
hey that's more than what it says on the
menu this I'm doing the White Castle
so which of the Batman movies were you
thinking about doing
like that and West Batman movie where
all the villains come together and try
to take them out exactly except with
more sharks
they say pettifog um